TO STEAL BECAUSE THE
ARENA.TEAM GIVING YOU TIME AND
BECAUSE OF THAT COLLISION ALONG
THE BOARDS, TWOOARDS, THE PUCK
WITH COLUMBUS.
PICKED UP
TO THEIR FRIENDS, TRIES TO DANF.
COLUMBUS CLEARS IT OUT. TO SHAR.
THEY SHOT DOESN'T GET THROUGH
HERE.
RIGHT THERE, STICK ON STICK.
GETS THE LOOSE THAT IS FOR
THE KINGS IN THE PAST.
IS RIGHT AROUND TOP TEN IN THE
NHL.
81  FIT THAT ANGLE ATTEMPT
NET.
ALL THE WAY BACK OUT, PICKS IT
AKE A WHILE.
KOPITAR, AROUND, PITCHES FROM
THE HALF WALL.
THE GIVEAWAY, SPINS IN THE
A T
THAT WILL FINISH OUTSIDE THE
WHERE THE NEXT GOAL IS HUGE
GREAT THE BLUE JACKETS GET THAT
GOAL,  CLEARED TO NEUTRAL ICE
.
THERE IS BOQVIST.
BE COMMITTED TO HIS SHOTS AND
USES THE SCREEN RIGHT NET VERY
WERENSKI DOWN THE LEFT BOARDS.
DOESN'T GET THROUGH LEASE PUCK.
THIS STAY-AT-HOME GUY, THE GRIN
IT OUT FLOCK SHOTS ALL THOSE
TYPES OF THINGSE, DENVER
ALUM WAS VERY NO CHANCE OF MAKI
PLAYOFFS.
>> THEY WEWETHERE. MENTIONED AT
COUPLE WITH A COUPLE OF HANDY
ISSUES,MISSES THE NET.
THIS WAS SOMETHING OUT OF
PUTS
STATIONARY HERE FOR A FOUR ON
THREE.
NOW THEY GET HIM OFF THE GAVRIK
TIME OFF FOR
>> I THOUGHT THE SHOT BLOCKS IN
THE FIRST PERIOD HAD A BI
MOORE TURNS
WING.
THE SHOTS OFF BY QUICK.
PICKS IT UP, FIVE AND HAVE TO GO
.
THANKS IT'S OFF T T